My name is Gretchen Rubin and this is the Happiness Project.
The resolution for this week is to reevaluate your mantras.
We all have mantras that go through our head often many times a day.
And you think about them without really even reflecting on the fact...
...that you're thinking about them. And yet they can have an enormous influence on the way that you act...
...and the way that you think.
So, for example, a mantra might be, "I have no self-control"...
...or "I'm so disorganized". And it goes through your head over and over.
And so by getting control of those mantras you can do a better job of taking control...
...of the way that you're thinking and acting.
And I realized it for myself. A mantra that went through my head many many times a day was,...
..."I'm so busy, I don't have time for that".
And I'd be going through my day and I'd be chatting with a friend...
...or I'd be reading some article that I was interested in but that had nothing to do with anything.
And I think, "Oh, I'm so busy I don't have time for that".
And then I realized, "That's not true".
I've changed my mantra. Now, my mantra is,...
..."I have plenty of time for the things that are important to me".
Because I realized that my mantra was making me feel harried.
It was making me feel like there's all these things that I wanted to do...
...that I didn't have time for, that I would have done if I could.
And just feeling pressed and just like there is this relentless pressure.
Now, when I say, "I have plenty of time for the things that are important to me",...
...it focuses my attention on figuring out what my priorities are.
If it's important to me, I have time for it. But I have to be honest about what's important to me.
That's the thing. You have plenty of time for the things that are important to you.
But just be honest about what's really important to you.
So, the resolution for this week is to reevaluate your mantras.
And the thought for this week comes from Thoreau,...
...who said, "I love a broad margin to my life."